[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo parece impresionante en los eeuu
los años locos ha vuelto la economía
crece hay pleno empleo los salarios
suben y se están recortando los
impuestos mientras los ingresos del
gobierno están en máximos históricos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y en los eeuu todo parece ir viento en
popa ya toda vela echemos sino un
vistazo al s p500 el índice bursátil más
importante el índice que recoge la
cotización de las 500 mayores empresas
cotizadas en los eeuu pues bien llevamos
nueve años viendo subidas
ininterrumpidas
creo amigos que no sería descabellado
decir que si echamos un vistazo al
gráfico de este índice nos recordaría
mucho la trayectoria de vuelo de uno de
los cohetes de hilo más
[Música]
no me creéis pues atentos al dato desde
el año 2009 es decir en menos de una
década el s p500 incluyendo los
dividendos ha tenido una rentabilidad de
más del 400 por ciento sabéis cuánto
supone esto pues para que os hagáis una
idea si hubiésemos invertido digamos
diez mil dólares en el año 2009 en el s
p500 hoy tendríamos 50 mil no está mal
verdad
eso sí que es multiplicar los panes y
los peces en los últimos años amigos ha
sido tan fácil ganar dinero los mercados
que casi que cualquier cuñado ha podido
sentirse como el mismísimo gordon gekko
pero amigos esperad un momento antes de
lanzar las campanas al vuelo porque
tengo una pregunta es todo realmente tan
bonito o acaso tiene la economía de eeuu
una cara oculta una cara menos
glamourosa pues amigos atentos
[Música]
en el gran dragón
wang 6
la otra cara
en visual polític solemos decir que las
cosas nunca son tan perfectas como
parece si en estos momentos eeuu es todo
una locomotora económica una locomotora
de alta velocidad
especialmente para todas aquellas
personas que han invertido como hemos
visto en las bolsas de eeuu sin embargo
amigos la gran potencia norteamericana
tiene un problema es adicta al crédito
tal cual como lo escucháis empresas
familias gobiernos gracias a años y años
de tipos de interés por los suelos y de
crédito casi limitado gracias a las
políticas de la reserva federal
prácticamente todas las instituciones de
este país devoran deuda
[Aplausos]
y veréis tras la gran crisis de 2008 los
principales bancos centrales del mundo
decidieron poner en marcha una política
que podríamos describir simplificar de
esta forma si emitimos es decir si
creamos más dinero lo que popularmente
se conoce como darle a la máquina de
imprimir más y más billetes y también
fijamos tipos de interés muy bajos
podemos lograr dos objetivos
por un lado lograremos que los bancos
presten dinero a familias y empresas
para que consuman e inviertan y además
las empresas que tengan problemas podrán
lograr financiación y no tener así que
cerrar de esta forma la máquina de la
economía podría volver a ponerse en
marcha por otro lado con todo este nuevo
dinero también podemos financiar a los
gobiernos de tal forma que no tengan que
hacer recortes severos del gasto y sigan
consumiendo
suena bien verdad pues esperar un
momento porque hay un pequeño problema
pequeño enorme veréis esta receta este
plan también tiene consecuencias porque
no estamos hablando sino de dopaje de
dopar la economía y amigos cuando
hablamos de dopaje económico hablamos
fundamentalmente de dos cosas de deuda y
de inflación no me creéis pues atentos
[Música]
en los últimos años eeuu está viviendo
una época dorada
se venden más coches que nunca el
negocio inmobiliario ha vuelto a
despegar y todo tipo de productos vuelan
de los estantes de las tiendas
claro que todas esas compras hay que
pagarlas la deuda de las familias
estadounidenses se encuentra en máximos
históricos y supera los 13 billones de
dólares esto es más de 40 mil dólares
por ciudadano
[Música]
pero amigos si pensáis que aquí termina
todo
sabéis que estáis muy equivocados si en
vez de echar un vistazo a las familias
se lo echamos a las empresas la
situación que nos encontramos es muy
pero que muy parecida
las empresas no financieras de los eeuu
acumulan deudas de más de 8 billones de
dólares su nivel de apalancamiento hoy
es superior al de 2008 y la mayor parte
del incremento de toda esta deuda no ha
ido a equipos fábricas ni nada parecido
sino a recomprar acciones y pagar
dividendos
[Música]
y amigos lo sé son cifras tan altas que
cuesta no perderse pero un momento ni
empresas ni familias suponen el mayor
problema el mayor problema de adicción
lo tiene
washington el gobierno federal y la
administración trump no se salva amigos
os hago una pregunta y no vale buscarla
en google para ver cuánto dinero será
hasta el año cuánto cuesta el gobierno
de eeuu atentos
el gobierno
[Música]
a comienzos de este año concretamente en
febrero de 2018 el departamento del
tesoro del gobierno de los eeuu publicó
su informe anual de 2017 es decir un
informe como el que presentan anualmente
las empresas que cotizan en bolsa un
informe donde dicen cuánto han gastado
cuánto han ingresado cuánto dinero deben
o cuáles son sus previsiones todo
recogido de una forma clara en un único
documento fácil de encontrar
sí creo que esta es una buena costumbre
del gobierno de eeuu pues bien amigos el
caso es que os doy mi palabra los
números son casi de película de miedo
en 2017 tan solo el gobierno federal es
decir sin contar los estados y los
municipios gasto o asumió compromisos de
pago por valor de 46 billones de dólares
vamos que por sí mismo el gobierno
federal estaría luchando por ser la
tercera mayor economía del planeta
nuestra mal verdad
menuda factura pero claro como os podéis
imaginar como los ingresos no van para
pagar todos los gastos pues el agujero
que de verdad tuvo el gobierno superó de
largo el billón de dólares eso sí que
son unas pérdidas en toda regla son más
grandes que toda la economía australiana
para que os hagáis una idea cada minuto
que pasa cada minuto el gobierno de eeuu
pierde más de dos millones de dólares sí
creo que si el gobierno de eeuu por una
empresa sus accionistas no estarían muy
contentos lo más sorprendente de todos
estos datos amigos es que para eeuu 2017
no fue un año de guerra ni de crisis ni
de recesión ni de nada por el estilo
fue un año normal bueno que digo normal
un año fabuloso un año de crecimiento
económico
[Música]
pero vale sabéis cuál es el resultado
pues que la deuda del gobierno federal
asciende a esta formidable cifra que
veis en pantalla 20 millones de dólares
más de 60 mil dólares por estadounidense
y ojo casi el triple más de 170 mil
dólares por contribuyentes
esto supone que la deuda de verdad del
gobierno de eeuu supera el cien por cien
del pib en la descripción os dejo por
cierto el enlace al documento del tesoro
pero bien tal vez sea en este tipo de
cosas las que expliquen noticias como
estas china amenaza reducirán las
compras de deuda de eeuu la deuda del
gobierno de eeuu en manos chinas se
reduce un 10% desde sus máximos
históricos pero sabéis que el presidente
de donald trump tiene un plan
[Música]
el plan del presidente
últimamente parecía que demócratas y
republicanos eran incapaces de ponerse
de acuerdo prácticamente nada sin
embargo amigos hay una forma de lograrlo
romper la hucha y repartirse la pasta y
eso es precisamente lo que ha ocurrido
en febrero demócratas y republicanos han
alcanzado el mayor acuerdo bipartito en
mucho tiempo para que pues para
incrementar el gasto público este
acuerdo cumple con nuestro compromiso de
financiar plenamente nuestra defensa
nacional no más tácticas y parches a
corto plazo por ryan presidente de la
cámara de representantes- con este
acuerdo el gobierno de eeuu incrementará
aún más el gasto público en concreto en
más de 150 mil millones de dólares cada
año más madera y eso que los
republicanos se pasaron ocho años
criticando y criticando al presidente
obama por manirroto
[Música]
es decir que ningún servidor boeninger
fan
y si es que el poder lo cambia todo
porque amigos comprendamos a los
políticos de washington no me digáis que
no os gustaría gastar a manos llenas con
un dinero que no es vuestro
pero aquí no acaba todo os acordáis de
la reforma fiscal de trump que se acaba
de aprobar os hemos hablado de ella aquí
en visual político en este vídeo pues
como vimos con la reforma fiscal los
ingresos del gobierno van a bajar
bastante así que una pregunta si bajamos
los ingresos y subimos el gasto que
tenemos exactamente un déficit aún más
grande
tanto que se espera que en 2019 el
déficit del gobierno de los eeuu se
sitúe entre el 5 y el 6 por ciento del
pib un déficit enorme propio de un país
en crisis porque vale cuando hay una
crisis todos podemos entender que los
gobiernos tengan agujeros enormes en sus
presupuestos baja el empleo baja la
recaudación etcétera etcétera pero
cuando todo va bien
si nos dijeron que trump llegaba para
poner orden y poner fin al desenfreno de
washington pero amigos parece que al
final ha decidido apuntarse a la fiesta
por todo lo alto pero por todo esto que
hemos visto cada vez más expertos se
preguntan quién va a comprar toda esa
deuda porque claro en los próximos años
el tesoro de eeuu va a tener que emitir
millones billones de deuda para pagar
todo este desajuste y en principio los
tres mayores prestamistas de eeuu esto
es la reserva federal china y japón- ya
no son compradores así que el resultado
parece que puede ser este esperamos que
las tasas de interés en aumento y un
nivel de deuda en aumento
conduzcan a un aumento significativo del
gasto de intereses en fin amigos así
están las cosas esta es la otra cara
menos atractiva de los eeuu espero que
con tanto número no os haya resultado
difícil seguir este vídeo pero pensamos
que era importante contar os la otra
cara la cara más oscura de la economía
de eeuu para que podáis saber de verdad
cómo están las cosas y por qué en
washington deberían empezar a tomarse un
poquito
este problema y no imprimir billetes no
es la solución cada vez que se imprimen
billetes se genera más deuda y más
inflación y ocurren cosas como esta el
dólar cae a su nivel más bajo en tres
años y ya hemos visto aquí en visual
político lo importante que es tener una
moneda fuerte una moneda sólida pero
ahora turno para ti crees que los
políticos de washington deberían
recortar el gasto público déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo no te olvides de
darle a like y suscribirte al canal si
aún no lo has hecho un saludo y hasta la
próxima